yeah so I watched and then reviewed Jim
and Andy the great beyond was on a huge
man on the moon kick watched man on the
moon I was like I want to talk about
that to waste not so here we go
man on the moon so man on the moon is
the biopic about Andy Kaufman this is
not Jim and Andy the great beyond which
is a documentary of the making of and
Jim Carrey's role in men on the moon
which is the biopic of Andy Kaufman is
the millers forming director movie about
Andy Kaufman starring Jim Carrey as Andy
Kaufman when this movie came out I knew
nothing about Andy Kaufman I didn't know
who this guy was
I'd seen a couple episodes of taxi I was
like yeah I guess he's the guy attacks
it but the fact is you don't have to
know the subject of the biopic in order
for a biopic to be interesting that's
what man on the moon does he follows
Andy Kaufman's life and his rise to fame
his rise to infamy really Andy Kaufman
was known for like I said in my review
of Jim and Andy the great beyond Andy
Kaufman was ultimately a troll before we
knew what a troll was he liked messing
with people it's apparent and it's funny
in a very dark way when you're watching
it through the eyes of this biopic you
know you're like he's doing it on
purpose to get a rise out of people but
it was happening people just thought he
was an [ __ ]
it's kind of cool to see through the
light of he wasn't necessarily an outlaw
right saying he wasn't an [ __ ] like
saying any troll on the internet it's
like they're not an [ __ ] they're just
a troll so things he did make him an
[ __ ] that doesn't mean he was a bad
dude Jim Carrey's performance in man on
the moon Melo's for me the director said
I never worked with Jim Carrey it was
either Andy Kaufman or Tony Clifton or
foreign man you don't really see the
full extent of that until Jim and Andy
the great beyond but really it's
apparent that he really did delve into
this role Jim Carrey is gone man is Andy
Kaufman every year when the Oscar
nominations come out my uncle and I
talked about the Best Actor nominations
and the nominations as a whole and
inevitably we talked about that year Jim
Carrey was snubbed for at least a
nomination for his role and that is for
man on the moon that's right no Oscar
nomination for Jim Carrey the year this
came out it's strange I don't know why I
really do feel he deserved an Oscar
nomination at least for his role in this
movie and I felt like that for the past
17 years and the supporting cast is
impressive I mean Courtney Love is
Courtney Love and I can't think of a
scenario where I've seen Courtney Love
in a movie and I'm like only she could
have played her she's the one who really
doesn't stand out to me but Danny DeVito
has ship
his agent the veto is great and I think
it's advantageous to have him in that
role not only as Mueller's foreman
worked with Danny DeVito before but
Danny DeVito worked with Andy Kaufman on
the set of taxis so Danny DeVito knows
Andy Kaufman and Paul Giamatti as Bob
zmuda Andy Kaufman's best friend Paul D
I love Giamatti I'm waiting for him to
get an Oscar because he promised that if
he ever got an Oscar in his speech he
would think Howard Stern I just want to
see a bunch of old people's minds melt
the académie just looks like they opened
the lost Archer but this is a couple
years after he was on private parts oh
he played Pig vomit Howard Stern's boss
a total [ __ ] then he goes to playing
Bob zmuda it really does show the range
in Paul Giamatti not just range but
shows that he's really good at comedy to
be it biopic dark comedy what you see
Andy Kaufman was doing is ultimately
building his Andy Kaufman Cinematic
Universe if you will he wanted to create
a contained bubble of entertainment like
he did in his bedroom when he was a kid
Andy Kaufman's the good guy that he
created Tony Clifton the villain Tony
Clifton going on to the set of taxi he's
one of the best things I've seen then he
wanted to be the villain so he did the
women's wrestling thing then Jerry
Lawler steps in and really all of it was
just a ruse it was just a farce it was
[ __ ] for entertainment but it was
[ __ ] for entertainment for the sake
of Andy Kaufman's entertainment and it
really shows a man walking the line of
who do you want to entertain the
audience or yourself a lot of this was
entertainment for himself it looks like
it was pretty good entertainment for him
to I don't know you're trolling the
entire world getting a rise out of
everybody if that's what Andy Kaufman
was going for well then he succeeded
where the movie starts to falters really
it is biopic 101 there really is the
path you've seen a hundred times before
another biopic or movies in general but
maybe you see it in a lot of movies
because that's generally speaking how it
goes if someone just climbs to success
and that's it now they're successful
it's not really interesting enough to
make a movie about that I mean it can
happen it's just not the most
interesting path we like damaged people
Andy Kaufman was definitely a damaged
artist and the movie does start to lose
momentum after the whole cancer
diagnosis happens granted how much
momentum is it supposed to keep is a
cancer diagnosis not supposed to be a
fun time after that I'm just saying the
build-up before that was so much more
interesting than all right now if cancer
now is dealing with it and it sucks
I liked him messing with the studio
execs before that I liked him messing
with
vertical guys in the end those
shortcomings aside man on the moon is
fascinating it's entertaining really
well acted well directed it's a look
into the mind of someone who truly did
have a unique mind especially for his
time some liked Andy Kaufman some didn't
this movie really shows the person
behind the facade if for nothing else by
the end of this movie you feel like Andy
Kaufman's madness it's because he truly
understood the world in a way that a lot
of people don't and I feel like a lot of
that's rubbed off on Jim Carrey seeing
him in Jim and Andy the great beyond and
I really do believe a mindset like that
truly is meant to be alone in the world
it's not nurtured by people people just
think you're crazy think you're a nut if
for nothing else they think you're an
[ __ ] so you have these people that
see the world on a different level than
a lot of other people in the world and
they're forced to talk about it with the
people who can really relate which are
themselves lonely existence really and
by the end this movie really does make
me personally think of my own mortality
I think about my funeral a lot I don't
know if as morbid I just do I think
about what will people think what people
say how will people feel in the end of
this movie I'm always left with that
feeling of I hope my funeral one day is
half as uplifting as Andy Kaufman's
funeral in man on the moon that's all I
can really hope for in life there's some
people who love the movie some people
think this movie's alright I'm one of
the ones who loves it I feel like if you
watch it you'll laugh you'll be
entertained you'll be fascinated so
watch it let me know what you think or
if you've seen it man on the moon have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more